so after four months of negotiation
Richie sunac will now press the button
on possibly the most important decision
of his career the deal between the
European Union and the United Kingdom
government has now concluded on brexit
Rishi sunac must now sell that deal to
his party to the unionists in Northern
Ireland MPS from all different bits of
the political system and the country in
order to get it through and change the
way Northern Ireland operates in the
United Kingdom post-brexit this is
possibly the biggest decision that Rishi
sunak has taken as prime minister it
will have profound impacts on Northern
Ireland and the way that brexit works in
future and what this announcement means
is that they've pressed fired the
starting gun on a whole series of events
in the next few hours expect Rishi sunak
to meet his cabinet pretty imminently
expect Rishi back to hold a press
conference with urester Wonderland then
after that you will get all the
documentation the legal text the
explanations for us all to pour over and
we'll be doing that here at Sky News in
some detail through the late afternoon
and evening and then into the evening
MPS will be given their first
opportunity to debate the deal that
Rishi sunak has struck no vote tonight
no vote tomorrow we understand but
nevertheless the first test of MP
opinion about this deal that will change
the way that the United Kingdom operates
that Northern Ireland sits within the
union and changes Britain's relationship
with Brussels a very important moment
for this prime minister can he get the
consent of everybody he needs that's
going to be the biggest political story
this week
and Sam you talk about uh consent and
you talk about uh the dup in particular
those unionists who will be pouring over
the detail once we get it what did you
make of what Sir Jeffrey Donaldson had
to say in the last uh 20 minutes or so
he tweeted uh that will take our time to
consider the detail and measure a deal
against our seven tests because some
were reporting that actually they were
behind this protocol there was enough to
satisfy them
so it's important to say that the
unionists in Northern Ireland possibly
the most important people in this debate
they're the most important people that
Richie sunac would need to bring on site
and the dup are absolutely Central to
that now as you say there were some
reports in Irish media that potentially
uh that potentially the dup were on
board but I think the dup leadership
very very clear that they're not going
to be bounced they're not going to make
a decision before they've even seen the
tech so Jeffrey Donaldson pouring cold
water on a report that there are all
sorts of attempts to sell the dep's
backing for the deal in the coming hours
Jeffrey Donaldson has a difficult
balancing act however much he might be
enthusiastic about some of the ways in
which Richard sunac has undoubtedly
solved key problems about Northern
Ireland's place within the United
Kingdom he has a difficult job ahead
convincing key figures in his party hard
brexite is in paisy junior Sammy Wilson
he needs to get those figures on board
and those brexite unionists in the rest
of the party so their consent can't be
taken forgiven so he's being cautious
today I think that Rishi sunak hoping
for any kind of dup help if not full
support is gonna have to wait a little
bit longer